coming from the iron Lords podcast today
I'm going to be unboxing a little
special present that Xbox sent me you
know I figured I'd go ahead and get this
out to you guys I want I want to do a
little bit more of these man you know
you guys respect our opinion you guys
know where I was gonna keep a 100. so
today they sent me it's an IOP they sent
us the hold up let me take it out of the
little bag
they sent us the core elite controller
so pretty much what this is it's their
Elite controller too uh but it does seem
like they're they're separating the
they're making a base unit for the elite
controller and as you can see here you
got the elite controller accessories so
pretty much what this is is them
together is an elite controller too to
my knowledge and them separated as other
you know making them a little bit more
affordable for a lot of people so here's
the Elite Series control two this is the
the actual core
if you look at it you know it's pretty
good packaging I'm not going to say it's
not you know
I'd like to be able to to focus that a
little bit better but the package is a
little good now there is like a little
bit of looseness in there I assume
that's like the paperwork and stuff uh
you know same thing with this one you
know you look
go ahead and adjust this a little bit
you know
nice little thing man it's like I said
nice little Packaging
it's not really loose for that one so
let's go and bring this one up real
quick
see that looks pretty nice I like the
packaging for the elite course they're
pretty good so let's go ahead and
Focus this back towards me
all right so what we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and open the
core one first now I do have a GoPro
above me uh hopefully I'll be able to
use that to give you guys a little bit
more of a close-up personal thing so
we're gonna go ahead and get rid of this
here now this is like I think the third
or fourth unboxing I've ever done I've
done some unboxings on my actual YouTube
channel so you know shout out to that if
you guys want to go check that out it's
a gaming addict uh so let's go ahead and
open this like I said the boxing's
pretty good kind of got a similar like
like
um Xbox series X thing where it just
pops open so let's go ahead and open it
or it's taken forever guys
it's taking forever
is it oh yeah see I'm an idiot there's
one on here too so let me go and get
that too
I'll probably
time code these because I think it'll be
easier to keep up for people that just
want to actually see it so
pretty easy you know you just
straight open you know a little nice
little little tightness to it
oh so that's what was
that's what was jiggling a little bit
it's a little piece that you put on the
the analog
so you know you put that on here
analog's pretty good
you know
I like the the feel of it
um I've never had an elite controller
too so you know this is the first one
when it comes to a core but you know I
like the way it feels now can you so
yeah you can still push these off like I
said this is pretty much an elite
controller uh an elite version too or
what do they call these things exactly
what's the exact name they like to call
these the Elite series two they're going
with this series branding so as you can
see pretty pretty good man pretty good
you know go ahead and
zoom in
oh
right there so as you can see you know
the control is in pretty good condition
no damages in shipping I like the white
and black like I said you know the all
these things pop out pretty easily
they kind of like have a little magnet
to it so that's how they get around that
for
people not messing it up
all right so
should probably put that auto focus on
now as far as the packaging you can see
here I'll probably try to put the GoPro
image throughout the packaging but I
know this camera is a little bit better
so I'll be using it some too
so you know it's got pretty much with
your basic hardboard stuff uh your basic
packaging is this looks like probably a
type D
uh it is a UBS to D to C type c you can
always use more of these this is kind of
it's kind of huge if you want if you ask
me it's a very long cord I actually like
that I need that
I need that
all right so obviously you got like you
know the little packaging you know we'll
go ahead and open that up real quick
you know
um
it's got one of these things I think
this is to Ticker with the analog and
it's got like a little bit of packaging
when it comes to what the Elite Series 2
is I wonder if they're gonna make an
Elite series three it's kind of
curious they made a core instead of just
making an elite so it kind of makes me
think maybe the elite isn't isn't coming
out anytime soon the Elite series three
hopefully we'll get a series there you
guys might never know man guys hit up
that like button get get us a series
three up in here
so so far so good you know there's the
first tool now
uh to my knowledge it's like 120 ish now
I know this is like 50 or 60 maybe even
70. I can't really get the the price too
too much
um but you can look it up it's pretty
much like the components to that like I
said originally you had the Xbox uh
series Elite Xbox Elite series two you
have the full controller and you had
everything in here was with it but I
guess Microsoft you know they want to be
a little bit more open to Consumers you
know obviously the cheaper products
gonna sell a little bit better because
people can afford it a little bit
so let's go ahead and take this one off
let's see what's in this this extra
Edition you know they put them together
they put them together for me shout out
to Microsoft so I can give you guys my
opinion on the packaging the product
itself
it is getting really annoying like they
they kind of pack it just a little bit
too good oh I'm an idiot I did it again
I guess it just like slides out
oh
you know let me just take it like this
just open it there we go there we go
got it
then you probably just yep just slide
right out listen to this
just a nice little filling man I like it
look at the packaging like I said you
know it slides right out there's the
case I'm assuming everything's in the
case that you need now as far as I know
this is a battery uh these aren't
batteries these are internal charge port
so that's probably why you have these
this long because this is a long quality
I don't know you guys can't fill this
but the quality to this d uh this USB to
C type it's it's good it feels good it's
pretty lengthy I don't know if that's
like four foot or something I don't know
it's kind of like a long it's really
long I'm really impressed by them
packaging that with the just basic core
Edition probably a 20 cord by itself to
be honest with you all right so now we
got this you know uh what's cool is they
got another cord in here you know like I
said let's go ahead and uh show the
actual thing so as you can see I got
some stuff up here got some more types
of information pamphlets up here
so first thing you see is you see this
another one of these Chargers like I
said these Chargers are really nice I
really like these Chargers then you got
whatever this is this looks like uh
something that you charge it on like a
stand
um let me look here how do I open it
uh
there we go what what is this
I don't know what this is oh
see I know you guys can't
see it looks like a charging station now
I know you guys can't really see this
but this feels quality it feels heavy
feels nice
um is that all that's in here
I believe so
hold up
yeah so that does look like that's all
that's in there kind of disappointing a
little bit on that oh because I felt
like it should have been a little bit
bigger
I don't know hold up
well never mind it fits pretty good
never mind
but this this does feel like quality and
there's the UB uh the uh the
the sea port I wish they would had a c
to C that would have been nice uh then
you got like your standard just regular
stuff that you put on there the paddles
the extra analog and then you got your
uh selection when it comes to how you I
d-pad and then you got the analog so you
know these are pretty nice man I
actually really enjoy these I think
they're nice I will be doing a review on
them and seeing exactly how you guys
feel about it right now just the
unboxing you know of both of them
and I I like what I feel though I like
what I feel I don't I've never used
these these these back pedals and the
reason that I've always been curious
with these is because people always talk
about these back pedals but I've never
been able to get my hands on them and
I'm very curious how they work now I
think I'm doing it wrong
I'm definitely doing it wrong but this
isn't an assembly thing but that is the
unboxing of the
Elite Series 2 Xbox controller once
again shout out to Microsoft and Xbox
for sending over the iron Lords podcast
a review unit so we can look at it
clearly they sent it to us so uh you
know I appreciate everything to you guys
and until next time this is Lord addict
IOP out